la Feria Internacional del Libro de
Guadalajara están viendo sus últimos
días aquí en México una edición número
36 marcada por la participación de más
de 600 escritores de 45 países distintos
y 18 idiomas diferentes y se nos da que
este año la feria está mirando hacia el
mundo árabe por primera vez el tercero
más grande de los siete emiratos que
conforman los emiratos árabes Unidos es
el invitado de honor de la feria y del
lado de los artistas algunas voces
importantes de la literatura de árabe
estándar presentes como el palestino
adonis un pionero de la poesía moderna
árabe y es su primera vez en la feria
del libro de Guadalajara nos compartió
su alegría de estar acá
es muy importante tener ferias como esta
porque es realmente un punto de
encuentro extraordinario y casi único la
One
ahí estamos todos de todas las lenguas y
nacionalidades o civilizaciones todos en
la misma casa y eso demuestra que el
hombre puede crear un mundo de paz y
amistad dejemos Las Guerras el
capitalismo y todo eso
les sontón
después de nueve días de conferencias
charlas y encuentros entre Editores
autores y lectores la Feria
Internacional del Libro de Guadalajara
sus puertas este domingo